the gyro can experience the whole
southpaw thing
shout out to my boy [ __ ] and ideas like
in all the work we've done and can't
like those guys got me ready for a lot
of myself part opponents like you know
midway through and toward the end of my
career so a lot of work with those guys
and specifically Nate at a certain point
I stopped working with Nick because he
was doing other things but Nate men and
then the volume and having to like deal
with the awkwardness and the height in
the reach and like that got me ready for
Chad Dawson that's amazing that's my boy
yeah he's a tough dude man you know
watching him come back after three years
out of the game yeah he Pettis like I
shot him a message I was like bro you
bad man bad man like three years really
he's a bad man well I'm just happy that
the UFC is finally recognizing the love
and support that guy has from the fans
too because for whatever reason they
were so high on Conor McGregor and all
these other people they didn't see one
of the reasons why the Conor fight was
so big was cousin Nate Diaz Nate Diaz is
a [ __ ] star when he when they put his
face on the screen for the Pettis fight
I mean the arena erupted it was chaos
they went nuts I mean I don't know why I
couldn't see
I mean Conor obviously was you know he
was a little bit different he brought
what he brought to the table but
probably would have been a good thing to
try to balance him both out show love to
Nate but you know he was like the rebel
child you know gonna say whatever came
in was mine and you know that the powers
that be I don't like that I think he was
a little overshadowed by his brother too
because you know when four others a
superstar there's something about I mean
especially like his brother when he was
fighting in Strikeforce in particular it
was one of the best fighters in the
world he was just amazing and then you
know especially like you know during
like his title reign like when he was at
at its peak and when he's fighting in
Strikeforce but for whatever reason they
just you know Nate just flew under the
radar until that kind of McGregor fight
yeah first one yeah then they recognized
yeah I hope they capitalize on it now
you know why still is a few years left
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's it's that whole
layoff thing and not even trying to stay
relevant but just trying to keep your
skills from eroding like that's a whole
thing right there and then and then
trying to go perform after that amount
of time like it's hard you know me and
I've fallen from that
yeah not coming back the same he didn't
was a beat was crazy he looked as good
as ever it was a good thing is though he
seems to always be working yeah and
that's what saved me when I was off like
just always like chipping away in the
gym you know he's got you know him and
his brother got they got their own
schools and they're always in they're
grappling working out so that's what
saved him if you take off three years of
nothing two years of nothing a year of
nothing that's when you come back and
you look like a totally different person
I always point to Muhammad Ali when
Muhammad Ali was forced to retire when
he took three years off and then he came
back he did not look physically like the
same guy yeah you know he who did he
come back and fight it wasn't Chuck
Wepner it was with the Foxes was a zero
folly no no no no no it was
[ __ ] the it's a tragic guy a white dude
and then his brother was also like I
cannot remember Jamie pulled up I know
you're talking about to Cory yes Jerry
quarry